[Music]  our aim was to create a plant with a  scent that makes its owner happy we are  entering a new era here the first mood  lifting antidepressant happy plant we've  received orders from all over the world  I just wanted to say that I feel really  proud to be working with you look what I  have for you what do you say we call him  Little Joe you have to take good care of  it keep it warm talk to it it needs  attention also special about it makes  you happy haven't you noticed how chris  has changed  I think it'll Joe's pollen has triggered  something the tool Joe changes the  people he infects your starting status  tool aren't you fear can distort our  perception of reality if I make a  mistake then it's my fault it seems that  this is open a bit much for you  frightens me you're a good mother  but which of your children will you  choose  [Music]  you  [Music]